So we arrive at our turn to socio genesis and genesis is of course here,
uh,
obviously even as we read both Galison Bactine for today,
a misleading term,
uh,
in a certain sense because,
obviously the most egregious difference between [inaudible] and [inaudible].
And once again,
you're probably saying to yourself,
well my goodness,
why have these two texts been put together?
The most egregious differences that,
uh,
buck teens primary primary concern is with the life world that produces a,
a text,
uh,
and yelless his primary concern is with the life world or perhaps better
succession of life worlds in which in which a text is received.
I think you can tell however,
from reading both texts and we'll be,
um,
conscious,
uh,
as,
as you go through the materials that remain on the syllabus,
that the relationship between the production and reception of literature or of
discourse of any kind,
once you factor in the social setting of such a text becomes much more
permeable,
much more fluid.
There's a certain sense in which the producer is the receiver,
uh,
in which the author is the reader.
They author stands in relation to a tradition to a past as a reader and the
reader in turn,
uh,
in continuing to circulate texts through history.
That is to say in playing a role as someone who keeps texts current is perhaps,
uh,
even concrete,
even in concrete terms,
a writer that what that is to say someone who expresses opinions,
uh,
circulates values and keeps texts.
As I say in circulation,
this,
I mean,
I've always felt this about,
about Yos as sense of what a reader is.
Um,
what kind of reader would it be who was responsible for the continued,
uh,
presence,
influence of a text through literary history,
who wasn't in some sense communicating and opinion.
This is obviously truer today than ever before when we have blogs and discussion
groups and when everybody,
everybody is circulating opinions on the Internet.
Um,
plainly the reader plainly the tastemaker reader as tastemaker,
uh,
is at the same time a writer,
just in passing,
uh,
this has become a digression,
but I hope it useful.
One,
Justin passing in this context,
one can think about,
uh,
a really strange pairing.
Uh,
yes.
In relation to bloom if blooms theory of strong misreading as a principle of
literary historiography can be understood as a relationship between writers,
as readers and readers as writers.
So by the same token,
if we see a yellow yosses,
uh,
analysis of reception in these terms,
and if we think of reception as a necessary circulation of opinion,
there is after all a sense in which for a outs to the reader is a writer and the
writer as a reader,
um,
that is,
uh,
undoubtedly a remote connection,
but it is a way of seeing how both bloom and youse are figures who have strong
and interesting and plausible theories,
uh,
about literary history.
All right.
To go,
however,
back to the beginning,
back to the,
the sense in which we're at a watershed,
a or a moment of transition in this course,
leaving for the moment,
uh,
out of the picture,
the intermediate step of psycho genesis.
Uh,
to go back to the sense of our being in a moment of transition,
uh,
as always,
such as the calendar,
just at the wrong time.
We finally accomplish our transition.
Then we go off for spring break,
forget everything we ever knew,
uh,
and come back and start off at once again as a Tabula Rasa.
But we'll do our best.
We'll do it.
We'll,
we'll do our best to bridge that gap.
In any case,
if we now find ourselves understanding in reading these two texts for the first
time,
really,
uh,
although it's not that we haven't been talking about life before,
obviously we have been and it's not as though,
uh,
the Russian formalists culminating in the structuralism of your cups and don't
talk about a referential function.
I mean,
it's not a,
it's unfair even to the new critics to say that somehow the world is excluded
from the interpretive or reading process.
Even though all along we've been saying things like this,
we still sense a difference.
The difference is in the perceived relationship between the texts,
the object of study and the life world.
The sense in fact in which a text is a life world.
Uh,
and this has,
after all,
something to do,
something to do with our understanding of what language is.
So far,
we've been thinking of language as a semiotic code or,
and,
and also,
uh,
with the strong suspicion that this semiotic code is a virtual one.
We have been emphasizing the degree to which we are passive in relation to,
or even as it were spoken by this language.
In other words,
it's been a constant in our thinking about these matters.
That language speaks through us,
but we have exercised so far,
uh,
curious reticence about the sense in which this language is not just a code,
not just something that exists virtually at a given historical moment,
but as in fact a code made up of other people's language and other words that it
is language in circulation,
not just language as somehow abstractly outside of networks of circulation
available for use.
So we begin now to think of language still and the relationship between language
and speech,
but now it's not a language abstracted from reality.
It's a language which precisely circulates within reality.
Uh,
and as a matter of social exchange and social interaction language is now and
hence forth on our syllabus,
a social institution.
It has the same in literary theory.
It has the same determinitive relationship with my individual speech.
I mean,
we now begin to understand,
uh,
the claim that I don't speak my own language in a different register,
Heather too.
It's been,
well language is there before me.
What I speak is just sort of that which I borrowed from it.
But now,
uh,
this takes on a new valence.
They altogether,
but I don't speak my language.
It's other people's language.
My voice,
the word voice is obviously is obviously under heavy pressure here.
Even though nobody says it goes away.
My voice is a voice permeated by all the sedimentation registers,
levels,
orientations of language in the world that surrounds me.
I take my language,
in other words from other people,
I stand here,
uh,
for my sins,
a lecturing in a kind of an ad Lib way.
Uh,
and that makes it even more pronounced in what I say.
you're hearing the Internet,
you're hearing newspaper headlines,
you're hearing slang,
you're hearing all sorts of low qeustions and rhetorical devices that it would,
that I'd be ashamed to call my,
uh,
it at least in many cases because they are in the world.
They're out there as we'd say.
And what's out there gets to the point where it's in here and the next thing you
know,
it becomes part of the ongoing pattern or blather of an individual.
It is,
in other words,
the speech of others that you're hearing when you hear and individual the extent
or the degree to it's,
this might be the case is I suppose always subject to debate to debate.
We're going to,
we're going to take up a couple of examples but in any sense,
but,
but in any case,
you can see that that without the structure of the relationship between language
and speech having really changed and in fact it won't really change as we,
as we continue along without the structure of the relationship between language
and speech.
Having changed the nature of this relationship and the way in which we think of
it in social terms,
uh,
is changed.
And the social aspect of it now comes into prominence and,
and will remain there now in,
in order to see how this works.
In the case of our,
of today's two authors a little more concretely,
um,
I wanted to turn a two to a couple of passages on your sheet.
You got my grim warning last night that if that if you didn't bring it,
I wouldn't have any to circulate.
Uh,
we'll see how well that worked and if it didn't work well,
perhaps it will work better in the future.
In any case,
um,
first of all,
turning to the first passage on the sheet by Bach teen,
um,
by the way,
if you don't have,
if you don't have the sheet,
maybe somebody near you does a,
or maybe somebody near you has a computer,
uh,
which is being used for the correct purposes,
that can be that,
that,
that can be held somehow between the two of you.
Uh,
these are all possibilities.
the,
the first,
the first passage on the sheet,
um,
by buck teen,
uh,
is about the relationship between what he takes to be a formalist understanding
of double voice sadness.
Uh,
whether I mean,
for example,
the new critical understanding which he,
which he is not directly talking about,
but which we could use as an example of irony that the ways of talking about not
meaning what you say.
Uh,
and he's talking about those sorts of double voice sadness in relationship to
our,
in contradistinction to,
uh,
what he means by genuine Heteroglossia.
And he says,
first passage on the sheet rhetoric is often limited to purely verbal victories
over the word,
over ideological authority.
In other words,
uh,
I'm,
I'm sort of getting under your ribs,
uh,
if you're somehow or another,
um,
voicing a and authoritative or widespread or tyrannical opinion,
uh,
by some form or another of subverting it.
In other words,
a kind of a binary relationship between what I'm saying and what's commonly
being said out there.
When this happens,
when this happens,
it says buck dean rhetoric degenerates into formalistic verbal play,
but we repeat.
When discourse is torn from reality,
it is fatal for the word itself as well.
Words growth,
sickly,
loose,
sematic depth and flexibility.
The capacity to expand and renew their meanings in new living contexts,
they essentially die as discourse for the signifying word lives beyond itself.
That is,
it lives by directing gets purposiveness outward,
double voice sadness,
which is merely verbal,
is not structured on authentic Heteroglossia,
but on a mirror diversity of voices.
In other words,
it doesn't take into account the way in which there is a seepage or
permeabilities among the possibilities and registers of meaning depending on
extraordinarily complex,
uh,
speaking communities coming together in any aspect of discourse,
ways in which we have to think about the life world of a discourse in order to
understand the play of voice.
Heteroglossia,
you know,
is the language of others.
That's what it means in order to understand the way in which the language of
others is playing through and permeating the text.
Um,
and so,
uh,
then,
the,
uh,
comparable response response to formalism on the part of hunts.
Robert House,
I should say,
in passing that both Bactine and eos have authentic and close relations with the
Russian formalists Bactine,
uh,
begins in a way at the very end of the formalist tradition as a kind of second
generation formalists but quickly moves away,
uh,
which is breaking up in the late 1920s quickly moves away from that and begins
to write a kind of and begins to rewrite formalism in a certain sense,
uh,
as,
um,
a a socio genesis of discourse and our language.
Uh,
and by the same token,
yes,
uh,
in his theory of literary history,
which is not a enunciated in these terms in,
uh,
these people,
which is,
which is not enunciated in these terms in,
um,
in,
uh,
the texts that you have,
but rather in the long text,
uh,
which,
which I,
in a way,
I wish your editor had taken from which I wish your editor had taken an excerpt
called,
uh,
literary hisco literary history as a provocation to a literary theory.
You have,
you have excerpts from that on,
on your sheet.
Um,
in any case,
in,
in Yassas understanding of the relationship,
um,
between,
between the text and the life world.
Um,
I've completely lost my,
my place and my sense of what I'm doing.
Oh,
yes.
I'm talking about the Russian formalists.
I,
I'm,
I'm talking about the Russian formalists,
um,
uh,
yes.
Cobbles together as it were,
aspects of Russian formalists historiography,
particularly that of Yacob San Antonian off,
um,
and Maher,
a Marxist understanding of,
as it were,
the,
uh,
the marketing and reception and consumption of literary production.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and these and these pairs of ideas go together in his developing of his thesis
about literary reception to which we'll return at the end of the lecture in a,
in other words,
the,
uh,
the second passage on the sheet,
which distances him with in witchy.
He wants to distance themselves somewhat from both of these influences.
Uh,
it goes as follows,
early Marxist and formalist methods in common conceived the literary fact within
the closed circle of an aesthetics of production and representation.
In doing so,
they deprive literature of a dimension that in alien,
ugly belongs to its aesthetic character as well as to its social function,
the dimension of its reception and influence.
In other words,
the way in which a text,
once it exists,
moves in the world.
The way in which it presents changes as we understand it,
uh,
and grows or diminishes,
as time passes in the world.
This is the medium,
the social medium in which your wants to understand,
uh,
literary intern precisely literary interpretation as we'll see coming a little
closer to this issue of the relationship between thinking of this kind,
uh,
and formalists a formalist traditions in Bactine.
Uh,
on page five 92,
the lefthand column,
uh,
toward the bottom,
I'm not going to quote this,
I'm just going to say that it's there.
Uh,
Bactine begins a sentence,
uh,
about as he puts it literary parody understood in the narrow sense.
Now what he's implying here is that the theory of parody belongs primarily to
Russian formalists literary historiography.
In other words,
the relationship between a new tax than an old text is one of broadly conceived
within this discourse parody.
Um,
and so,
uh,
mark team picks up the word a parody in order to say also on page five,
also to say on page five,
92,
uh,
the lefthand column,
um,
but halfway down Amir concern for language is,
and that's an odd thing to say American are for lifers.
Americans aren't for language is but the abstract side of the concrete and
active.
I eat dialogic Lee and gauged understanding of the Living Heteroglossia that has
been introduced into the novel and artistically organized within it.
In other words,
parody.
If we,
if we linger merely on that literary,
on the literariness of parody,
we simply don't have any grasp of the complexity of ways of the ways in which,
uh,
the dialogic,
or the header or gloss will,
uh,
modulates,
and ripples and makes complicated the surface of literary discourse.
Parody once again leaves us with a sense of the Byron of the binary.
The,
for the previous text was this,
uh,
the secondary texts or the lake or the next text rifts off that previous text in
a way that we can call parotic.
Uh,
but that's binary.
That's just,
it's one text against another and leaves out the whole question of those,
of that flood or multiplicity of voices,
uh,
which,
which pervades the text.
Okay.
Now,
um,
and so then,
uh,
Yo [inaudible] has an interesting moment again back on your sheet,
in which he is the fourth passage on your sheet in which he is,
uh,
obviously directly responding to that passage.
Uh,
at the end of 10 yanos essay on literary evolution,
which we've had on the board and which we've discussed before,
you remember to neon off,
makes the distinction between evolution the way in which a sequence of texts,
uh,
mutates as one might say,
the way in which,
in other words,
a successive texts again parody or alter a what was in the previous text and
modification,
which is the influence,
uh,
on texts from the outside by other sorts of historical factors,
which may lead to textual change.
And 10 Yanoff says that it's important,
uh,
actually for both studies,
for the study of history and also for the study of literary history,
that the to be always kept clearly distinct,
um,
in the mind of,
of the person looking at them.
Well,
yes,
his response to that is perhaps chiefly rhetorical,
but it nevertheless once does mark the shift in the direction of the
understanding of language as social that I've been wanting to begin by
emphasizing y'all says the connection between literary evolution,
social change,
that is to say those features in society that would and do modify texts.
The connection between literary evolution and social change does not vanish from
the face of the earth through its mirror negation.
What is he saying?
He's saying does not vanish from the face of the earth because 10 yards,
10 Jano said it did.
I mean this,
there is no doubt that,
that,
that that's the passage.
Yeah.
This is talking about the new literary work he goes on is received and judged
against the background of the everyday experience of life.
In other words,
the work exists in a life world.
There is no easy or possible way of distinguishing between its formal
innovations and those sorts of innovations which are produced by continuous and
ongoing factors of social chains.
They interact,
uh,
they seep into one another in exactly the same way that all the registers and
sedimentation of human voices,
uh,
interact and seep into one another in Bach teens.
Heteroglossia all right,
so these then are the emphases of both of these writers with respect to
formalists ideas,
which I've played a prominent part in most,
if not all of the,
uh,
literary theory that we have studied that we've studied up until now.
All right,
now I'd like to linger a little while with [inaudible],
uh,
and then,
but before turning back to yes,
now Heteroglossia uh,
or diversity of speech as he calls it.
Sometimes he says at one point,
again,
on page five,
92,
uh,
toward the top of the left hand column,
Heteroglossia is what he calls the ground of style.
And I want to,
and I want to pause to ask a little bit,
what do you mean by this expression?
The ground of style,
the,
the italicized passage.
It is precisely the diversity of speech and not the unity of a normative shared
language that is the ground of style.
In other words,
I don't,
when I spin,
and I've already said,
of course when I speak,
I'm not speaking to you in a,
in an official voice,
I'm not speaking,
uh,
the king's English.
Uh,
in fact,
um,
on this view,
there's really no such thing as the king's English.
Nobody speaks the king's English because there is no such,
no such isolated distilled entity that one can point to a language,
at least the language of most of us.
Uh,
that is to say of everyone except people in hermetically sealed environments
like for example,
um,
a peculiarly privileged,
uh,
inward looking aristocracy.
The language of virtually all of us is the language of the people,
the language of others.
And it is that which we have to continue to think about.
Um,
as we,
as,
as we consider how a style is generated,
we speak of a style as though it were a question of purely a question of an
authorial signature.
Sometimes when we think of style and signature as synonymous,
oh,
I would recognize that style anywhere.
Kolrud set of words worth of a few lines of Wordsworth.
If I'd come across these lines in the desert,
I'd have said Wordsworth,
well obviously there's a certain sense,
there's a certain sense in which we do recognize the style.
For example,
the style of Jane Austin,
I suppose arguably you could think that this is the style of Dr. Johnson,
but most people would recognize it as the style of Jane Austen.
And yet at the same time as we'll see in a minute,
uh,
it is a style made up in ways that are very difficult finally to factor out and
analyze of many voices.
Um,
okay.
So,
so,
um,
this would suggest,
I think,
uh,
this idea of a style as a composite of speech segmentations,
this idea would suggest that possibly there isn't a voice that to speak of an
authorial voice would be a very difficult matter.
Um,
and in fact,
and might lead us to ask,
does this move the idea that the socio elect speaks through the video lack the
idea that the idea that the language of everyone is in fact the language that
speaks my speech,
my PR,
my peculiar,
uh,
individual speech.
Um,
does this once again bring us face to face with that dreary topic,
the death of the officer.
Uh,
I don't think so.
Not Quite,
certainly not inbox teen.
Um,
who gives us a rather bracing sense of the importance of the author in a passage
on page five 93,
the right hand column,
he says it is as if the author,
uh,
this is of course sort of coming face to face with the problem of whether there
still is an author.
He says it is as if the author has no language of his own,
but does possess his own style,
his own organic and unitary law governing the way he plays with languages.
So style is perhaps a Pq,
the eight ones particulare way of mediating and allocating the diversity of
voice.
That impinges on what one's saying.
Uh,
and the way his own real sematic and expressive intentions are refracted within
them and hear Bach Teen Saves or preserves the author by invoking the principle
of unifying intention and the way in which we can recognize it in the discourse
of any given novel.
Of course,
he goes on this play with languages and frequently the complete absence of a
direct discourse of his own and no sense degrades the general deep seated
intentionality,
the overarching ideological conceptualization of the work as a whole.
So this is not a,
though it may seem to be in certain respects,
a question of the death of the author as provoked by let's say Fuko or roll on,
barked at at the beginning of the semester.
So it's not that,
um,
exactly
all of it.
All,
everything that we've been saying so far can be seen to work in a variety of
novels.
The novel is the privilege,
John Rhe for Bactine.
He,
I think perhaps somewhat oversimplifying.
And this,
uh,
reads the novel,
the emergence of the novel,
the flowering and richness of the novel against the backdrop of Genres he
considers to be Mano Glassell,
uh,
the epic,
which simply speaks the unitary voice of an aristocratic tradition,
the lyric which simply speaks to the unitary voice of the sort of isolated
romantic,
solid cyst.
And over against that and over against that you get the poly gloss will rich,
uh,
multiple multiplicity of voice in the novel.
As I say,
I think that this,
I think that the generic contest is somewhat oversimplified because nothing is
easier and more profitable than to read both epic and lyric,
uh,
as,
as manifestations of Heteroglossia it.
Just think of the Iliad.
What are you going to do if you really believe that it's gonna Gloss will with
the speeches of their sites?
Well,
you know,
okay.
Um,
in,
uh,
in any case,
the basic idea,
however,
um,
is I think extraordinarily rich and important.
And I thought we could try it out by,
uh,
taking a look for a moment at the first sentence of pride and prejudice,
which I'm sure most of you know.
Um,
and is plainly a,
an example of the relationship between what,
uh,
what Bactine calls common language.
It is a truth universally acknowledged.
In other words,
it's,
it's in everybody's mouth,
you know,
uh,
plainly a result of the relationship between common language and something like
authorial reflection or what he elsewhere calls internally persuasive discourse.
Uh,
now in traditional parlance,
this would be a speech which manifests irony,
the rhetoric of irony against which,
uh,
Bactine sets himself in the first passage on your sheet.
Um,
I mean,
how ridiculous that,
uh,
we'd say a Jane Austin doesn't believe this.
Um,
this is drawing room wisdom.
and everything in the sentence points to the ways in which it's obviously wrong,
even while it's being called a truth universally,
meaning the thousand people or so who matter.
In other words,
there are great many people who neither acknowledge nor care about any such
thing.
Um,
that,
uh,
um,
and then of course the idea that I'm a single man in possession of a good
fortune or indeed otherwise,
uh,
has nothing to do,
um,
but um,
but be in want of a wife.
Uh,
and that,
um,
and so obviously,
this is,
this is what is being said by not the man in the street,
um,
but by a drawing room culture.
Now,
even before we turn to the ways in which,
uh,
the,
the complication of the ways in which the sentence is being undermined.
A bear in mind that the plot of the novel confirms the truth.
In other words,
Darcy and Bingley,
both of them in possession of a good fortune do turn out very plainly to have
been in want of a wife and in fact procure one,
uh,
by the end of the novel.
That is precisely what the plot is about so that the conventions governing the
plot of pride and prejudice altogether confirm the truth that is in,
not that he's eating outs in this sentence,
even though it is a truth that is plainly to be viewed.
Ironically,
that in itself is,
is,
is quite extraordinary and I think reinforces our sense,
uh,
that this is one of the great,
first sentences,
uh,
in the history of fiction.
But,
but now I'm turning to the way in which we can think of it as something other
than a simple irony.
Of course,
there's this word want,
we've been thinking a lot about want lately because we've just gone through,
uh,
our psychoanalytic phase.
What exactly does this single,
what,
what is this?
What is this single man really want?
You know,
I mean,
in a way,
the,
the subtle pun in the word want,
which means both to desire and to lack,
you know,
if I lack something,
I don't necessarily desire it.
I just don't happen to have it.
Right.
But on the other hand,
if I want something,
I can also be said to desire it.
Um,
well why?
Well,
which is it?
Which is it,
uh,
is it,
a kind of lack that social pressure of some sort?
Uh,
is,
is calculated to fill or is it desire?
And if it's desire,
what on earth does it have to do with the good fortune?
I mean,
the,
there are elements of the romance plot,
which raised precisely that question.
You know,
that desire has nothing to do,
um,
with fortune,
a convenience,
social acceptability,
comfort.
All of those things have to do with fortune,
but desire,
we suppose having passed through our a psychoanalytic phase to be of a somewhat
different nature.
And so the complication of the sentence has to do actually with the question of
the way in which these,
the meanings of these words can be thought to be circulating and to create
ripples of irony of their own far more complicated than,
Oh,
you know,
the is much smarter than that.
So he doesn't mean that which is already a complication and produced by the fact
that her plot bears it out.
How can her plot bear it out if she's being so ironic?
You know?
And,
and of course there's,
there's obviously,
um,
the,
there's obviously a good deal more to say,
uh,
the,
um,
uh,
single man in possession of a good fortune.
Uh,
uh,
obviously mate,
not at all want a wife,
um,
for a variety of reasons that one could mention and that can't be possibly
completely absent from Jane Austen's mind.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
that has to be taken to account,
uh,
in itself.
And certainly,
and certainly it does.
MCKAYLA,
you have,
you have darkened us.
Uh,
uh,
oh,
that's okay.
I think it's this one.
Uh,
well,
we may have to remain dark.
I don't want to take up too much time with it anymore.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
this is,
this is all right.
This is all right.
It,
it,
it puts the sentence in a whole new perspective.
So Brett,
Brett,
perhaps I'll stop there.
Um,
but I think,
but I think you'll see it's the sauce.
It's the side of the second sentence.
The bears reflection.
Uh,
oh,
by the ways,
if I still visible,
uh,
that bears reflection,
um,
uh,
beyond,
you know,
I kind of simple binary of,
uh,
the sentence is spoken by,
um,
by the man and the drawing room,
the,
or a woman in the drawing room.
It's a,
it's idiotic.
It's obviously wrong,
we'd simply can't say that the style of the author is a style that is segmented
by and through,
uh,
complexities of circulated.
Meaning that really can't be limited by any sense of one to one relation of that
kind.
She didn't touch any,
she didn't touch any of those,
Huh?
I've just made a darker.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
So yes.
All right.
Um,
what else about Bach teen?
One more thing.
Um,
his idea of common language.
This is a,
this is not a concept that is supposed to have any particular,
any one particular value attached to it.
It's a little bit like,
like the rhizome.
Uh,
it could,
it could be good.
It could be bad.
Common language could be a kind of robber Layson,
carnivalesque subversive,
energetic,
a body of voices from below,
uh,
overturning the apple carts of authority.
Uh,
and,
and the fixed ways of a Maura been social order could be that,
uh,
but at the same time it could itself be the authoritative,
the reactionary,
the mindless common language would be that universality of acknowledgement,
which seems to go along with,
um,
unreflected knee jerk responses to what one observes and thinks about common
language has that whole range.
The important thing about it is that it's out there and that it circulates and
it re edited exists in relationship with what buck teen calls internally
persuasive discourse.
In other words,
the way in which the filtering together of these various sorts of language,
uh,
result in something like what we feel to be authentic.
I power of reflection,
uh,
a,
a posing of relation among the variety,
the,
the various strata of language.
Um,
so that's,
that they can speak authentically,
not necessarily in a way that we agree with,
but in a way that we recognize to constitute that distilled the consciousness
that we still do call the author and to which we'll describe in some sense,
um,
authority we feel,
precisely in the a peculiar,
uh,
self mocking relationship between this sentence of bride and prejudice and the
plot of pride and prejudice as a whole.
We feel something like the internal persuasiveness,
the coherence of the discourse.
Um,
and um,
I think maybe just to,
just to sum up buck dean,
I want to quote you from the other,
uh,
long excerpt that you have in your ontology,
which I would encourage you to read sometimes.
I have asked people to read it,
but I decided to drop it this year,
but it's still a very strong,
uh,
an interesting argument.
It's called discourse in the novel.
And I just want to read and the left hand column there,
the bar near the bottom of the column,
the ID,
the ideological becoming of a human being in this view is the process of
selectively assimilating the words of others.
Now there's the coherence of my mind of what I say insofar as it exists,
as the result of selecting out,
of selecting among in my assimilation of the words of others such that there is
a pattern of again,
coherence.
Uh,
all right,
so finally the novel is the social text far acts a loss for buck teen for these
reasons.
And it confirms again what we've been saying about a new way of thinking of
language language as that which speaks us is not just language,
it's other people's language.
And we need to understand,
uh,
the experience of the process of reading and of texts as they exist and the
nature of authorial comp composition as a at and it's simulated selective way of
putting together other people's language.
All right?
Now quickly,
yes,
he takes us back obviously,
uh,
by wave eser.
Uh,
I think you can see that,
uh,
that Yassas talk about horizons of expectation.
Uh,
the disruption of expectation has a great deal to do with ease.
There's understanding of the role of the reader in filling imaginative gaps that
are left in the text,
uh,
that,
which are based on a complex relationship with a set of conventional
expectations by way of Eser to Goddamn.
Because after all,
uh,
what y'alls has to say,
as a way of talking about God,
Hammers,
merger of horizons.
But for [inaudible],
it's not just my horizon and the horizon of the text.
It's not just those two horizons that need to meet halfway on common ground,
uh,
as mutually illuminating.
It is in fact a succession of horizons changing as,
as modes of aesthetic and interpretive response to texts are mediated
historically.
Uh,
as I say in a sequence,
uh,
it's not just the text was once a certain thing.
Now we feel it to be somehow different and in order to understand it,
we need to meet it halfway.
It's rather a matter of self consciously studying what has happened in between
that other time.
And this here and now the text has had a life,
it has passed through life changes and these life changes have to be understood
at each successive stage in terms of the three moments of hermaneutic grasp as
described by God [inaudible],
uh,
in the historical section of truth and method,
the distinction between into League era,
uh,
[inaudible] an athlete Carre understanding interpretation and application that
yells,
talks about at the beginning of his essay actually goes back to the 18th
century.
And what Y'alls has to say about it is yes,
these three moments of hermaneutic understanding exist for any reader or reading
public at any moment,
uh,
in the history of the reception of a text,
he makes a considerable to do about distinguishing between the aesthetic
response to the text and a subsequent or,
or leisured reflectively interpretive response to the,
to the text.
And this may seem a little confusing because he admits with Heidegger and others
as,
as we've,
as we've indicated ourselves in the past,
that you can't just have a spontaneous,
uh,
response to anything without reflection.
There's always a sense in which you already know what it is,
which is to say a sense in which you've already interpreted it.
But at the same time,
y'all,
this makes a considerable point of distinguishing between these two moments,
the,
the aesthetic which associates with understanding and the uh,
uh,
and,
and the interpretive,
which he associates with what is in the hermaneutic tradition called,
uh,
interpretation.
Now,
why does he do this?
It's a question of what he means by the aesthetic.
A text enters historical circulation and remains before the gaze of successive
audiences in history because it has been received aesthetically.
Aesthetics is the glue that keeps the text alive through history.
In other words,
people continue to say to one degree or another.
I like it if they don't say,
I like it.
There will never be a question of interpreting it or,
or transmitting it historically because it's going to disappear.
As Dr. Johnson said,
that book is good in vein,
which the reader throws away.
In other words from the staff,
from the,
from the stand point of interpretation or from the standpoint of philosophical
reflection or whatever you might wish to call it.
Um,
a book may be good just,
just incontestably good,
but if it didn't,
please,
if it didn't give pleasure,
if it didn't sort of attach itself to a reading public aesthetically by means of
pleasing none of what would succeed and then in the Hermeneutic,
a process could ever take place.
So that's,
that's why,
uh,
y'all make such a point of distinguishing between the aesthetic and the
interpretive and that of course,
the,
the historical study of reception is what shows us the degree to which any set
of,
uh,
moments of as of,
of aesthetic and interpretive reception is mediated by what has gone before it.
In other words,
a text gradually changes as a result of its reception.
And if we don't study it,
we're left naively supposing that it really hasn't,
that that time has passed,
that the past has become sort of remote from us.
So we have certain problems interpreting,
but these problems haven't arisen from anything that could properly be called
change.
Uh,
that there has been an unfolding process of successive interpretations whereby a
text has gone through see changes.
It's become less popular,
more popular,
more richly interpreted,
less richly interpreted,
uh,
but tends to keep eddying out from what it was sense to be originally to the
point where all sorts of,
of,
uh,
creative,
implications and sources of pleasure may arrive as we understand it in a certain
sense.
Once again,
it's like Pierre men,
art author of Don Quixote,
but now it's not just PR prepare,
uh,
Menard and Miguel de Cervantes.
It says though,
a succession of people perhaps writing,
you know,
perhaps whose native language was not French necessarily,
but who knows,
German,
Russian,
whatever.
Uh,
continuing to write in Spanish,
uh,
a text,
which turns out to be word for word,
uh,
Don Quixote as the centuries past each one acquiring a whole new world of
associations and implications and giving pleasure in successively new ways.
And when we finally get to the point in the late 19th century,
when we encounter this Frenchman Prm and are writing Don Quixote,
the important thing would be to understand that lots of people have done it
between him and Cervantes.
This,
uh,
on this,
this as a kind of skeletal model of how a reception history according to your
house might work.
Now it's red at the history of reception studies,
two things.
Uh,
it's studies,
uh,
changing horizons of expectation.
Uh,
and that's something you're familiar with,
uh,
from Eser.
That is to say the way in which a read your has to come to terms with a
convention surrounding expectation in any given text in order to be able to
negotiate what's new and what's nearly merely culinary and the text.
Uh,
it involves changing horizons of expectations with dope,
which don't just change once in the here and now,
but have changed successively through time.
And it also involves changing semantic possibilities,
uh,
or if you will,
changing possibilities for and of significance.
What does the text mean for me now?
But understood,
again,
not just as something that matters for me,
but has successively mattered for successive generations of readers in between.
Just to take examples of how this might work in the here and now.
There is just now on Broadway a revival of Damn Yankees,
uh,
which is about a baseball player who sells his soul,
in order to beat the Yankees.
Uh,
and one can't help but think that the revival of interest in Dan Yankees has
something to do with the steroid scandals,
uh,
and the way in which so many baseball players do sell their souls in order to
win and in order to have good careers.
Uh,
and it occurs to one that it is that it is in this sort of atmosphere of social
and cultural center,
uh,
that were suddenly interested in Damn Yankees again,
perhaps there will be a revival of Tony the tow truck,
uh,
because in the economic downturn,
obviously to be rich or to be glamorous,
you know,
speedy or to be busy,
to be,
you know,
oh,
the,
all of this becomes obsolete.
Um,
uh,
more or less irrelevant.
And beside the point,
and what really matters is little guys helping each other,
you know,
and so,
uh,
and so Tony,
the tow truck could,
can be revived today,
uh,
as a parable of the good life in the downturn.
Uh,
and,
and so it will probably be read by everyone,
uh,
give,
it will give pleasure that will therefore be interpreted,
uh,
and it will survive to live another day.
Historically,
uh,
fulfilling the three moments of the study,
of the history of reception,
uh,
required by,
yes.
All right.
So with that said,
it's been a very interesting 50 minutes,
I think,
uh,
with that,
with that said,
I hope you all have a good break,
uh,
and we'll see you when you get back.